MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
We have seen in
the previous video
how neutrinos can acquire mass.
When they have mask, ["mass"?]
their weak eigenstate is not
equal to their mass eigenstate.
So we observe the
same mixing as we
have seen in the quark sector.
So let's review
this a little bit.
So just starting from
two neutrino generations,
we can write the
flavoring states.
We are mixing of
mass eigenstate.
If we do this, it's
a simple matrix.
You find that there
is one angle used
for the rotation of
the mass eigenstate
into the flavor eigenstate.
All right.
So we can add some time
to 0, write our neutrino
or our muon neutrino as a
combination of the 1 and 2
mass eigenstates.
If we then have this
neutrino evolve as time,
we see that the relative
contribution of the 1 and 2
mass eigenstate
actually changes.
So if we do that, so obviously
you find some time evolution.
If we then ask ourselves,
what is the probability
that we start from
a muon neutrino
that we actually find in an
interaction electron neutrinos.
Through this mixing
of mass eigenstates,
we can calculate
this probability
just by squaring the amplitudes.
If you do this, you
just use this part here.
We find that there is a
cosine E2 minus E1 term.
All right.
Good.
So let's analyze this
a little bit further.
We know that the masses
need to be small.
So one thing we
can also do here is
do a Taylor expansion
of our energy and then
just revise the term.
If you then analyze
it some more,
you find that the oscillation
probability simply
depends on the mass difference
squared, the length of distance
the neutrino had time
from 0 to oscillate,
and the energy of the neutrino.
So this is fantastic,
because now
by studying the
probability for a neutrino
to change its flavor, we can
infer the mass differences
of two states.
This is fantastic.
I should add here that in
this case, in this formula,
the length is given in
meters, the energy is given--
unit of the energy MeV
and the mass difference
is in eV, otherwise the
equation doesn't make sense.
So again, we have seen, if
you start from two neutrino
kind of model, two
neutrino flavor model,
that the experimental
parameters of interest
here are the length of distance
from the neutrino source
to the detector on the
place where we generate
a specific neutrino
of a specific flavor,
to where we actually observe
the flavor of the neutrino
and the energy of the neutrino.
And then, the appearance
or disappearance
of a muon neutrino,
for example, if we
start from a beam
of muon neutrinos,
is a function of the
length of the source.
And this is shown here for
neutrinos of a specific energy.
So you can observe
or can try to measure
the disappearance
of muon neutrinos
or you can try to find
the appearance of electron
neutrinos in the specific
two-neutrino model.
All right.
So all we find later
is that we want
to look for disappearance
and appearance of neutrinos
of specific flavors in order
to probe mass differences.
Instead of doing this
for two generations,
you already know how to do
this in three generations,
you can find that
the unitary matrix
has three angles,
three rotations and one
complex phase.
And this looks
very much the same
here as in the quark sector.
The big difference is that
the values of those parameters
are quite different.
For the quarks, we have seen
it's dominated by the diagonal.
And then we have
seen, for example,
in the Wolfenstein
parameterization
that we can do an
expansion of the matrix
and see terms which are all of
this lambda, which would all
point to two and number
square and number acute.
Here, on the leptons
sector, the situation
seems to be quite different.
We have a later lecture where
we look at the extra parameters
and the numerical values.
But what you see
here is that it's
more like democracy between
the individual values.
Question is, do we
have sensitivity
to the complex phase?
We can only have
that sensitivity
if the value of this
matrix element is non-zero.
And this has been
observed already.
So that's good news in order to
allow further neutrino studies.
So in general, you can write
the oscillation from one flavor
to another flavor state using
this rotation of matrices
we have seen, and
with that measure
the individual
components of the matrix.